ansa está parado en un bote a una altura
de 5 pies sobre el nivel del mar
lars está nadando debajo del agua a una
altura de menos 7 pies debajo del nivel
del mar quién de los dos está a una
mayor altura podemos considerar que si
tenemos como nivel del mar una línea
digamos a esta altura
hans estar a 5 pies por encima de él
mientras large estar a 7 pies por debajo
de este podemos entonces decir que el
nivel de altura mayor será el de hans
que estarán aquí a 5 pies lo recuerdan
vamos entonces a seleccionar a hans
siguiente pregunta a quién de los dos
están más lejos del nivel del mar
aquí no se está preguntando el valor
absoluto recuerda que el valor absoluto
lo podemos pensar de dos maneras la
primera es que tan lejanos estamos del
cero en este caso hans
entre el 0 y el 5 tiene 5 posiciones o 5
lugares mientras que el arts está a 7
posiciones no importa que este sea un
negativo recuerda que nosotros estamos
buscando la distancia entre 0 y este
punto por lo tanto el valor absoluto lo
podemos considerar como 7 positivo y
justos en la segunda parte también
podemos pensar en el valor absoluto como
la versión positiva de estos números
tenemos 5 pies o el valor absoluto será
5 y tenemos menos 7 pies o su valor
absoluto que será 7 positivo de tal
manera que si nos preguntan quién de los
dos está más lejos del nivel del mar
pues podemos saber que será el ars que
está a 7 pies por debajo
colocaremos a large y comprobamos la
respuesta
es correcta hagamos un par más de estos
en su cuenta bancaria
martín tiene un saldo de 14.40 su amigo
y manuel tiene un saldo de 22 ni martín
ni y manuel tienen más dinero solo
podemos considerar este dinero que tiene
en 14.4 y 22 amigo tiene más dinero en
su cuenta esto está muy sencillo dado
que ambos números están del lado
positivo tenemos 1440 positivo y 22
positivo que amigo tiene más dinero en
su cuenta si lo miramos en una recta
numérica tendríamos tal vez el cero aquí
él 14.40 aquí y el 22 más adelante más
hacia la derecha por lo tanto el amigo
que más dinero tendrá es el de 22 que en
este caso es y manuel
siguiente pregunta cuál de los dos
saldos tiene un mayor valor absoluto
recuerda que este valor absoluto será la
distancia que tenemos hasta el cero
entre cero y 14.40 tendremos 14.40 y
entre el 0 y el 22 tendremos 22 por lo
tanto el valor absoluto mayor será el de
iu manuel una vez más vamos a escribirlo
y estaremos correctos revisemos nuestra
respuesta
es correcta vamos con uno más en su
cuenta bancaria de jon paul tiene un
saldo de cero pesos
su amigo albert tiene un saldo de menos
11.10 ni champions ni albert tienen más
dinero una vez más nos vamos a preguntar
qué amigo está más endeudado en este
caso jean paul tiene cero pesos ni debe
ni tiene dinero está en cero su amigo
albert si tiene un saldo de menos
11.10 significa que él debe dinero este
números negativos por lo tanto el que
está más endeudado bueno sin duda será
albert vamos a marcarlo aquí y nos vamos
con la siguiente pregunta que nos dice
cuál de los dos saldos tiene un mayor
valor absoluto volvemos a tomar el tema
del valor absoluto recuerda cuál es la
distancia que tenemos entre este punto y
el cero en este caso la distancia de
cero a cero pues es cero eso es muy
claro mientras que albert tiene una
distancia de menos
11.10 al cero
tendrá 11.10 como valor absoluto es
decir cuál de los dos saldos tiene un
mayor valor absoluto pues en este caso
será el de albert que su valor absoluto
es la versión positiva de este menos
11.10 que será 11.10
y comprobaremos nuestra respuesta
muy bien una más en su cuenta bancaria
sal y tiene un saldo de menos 200 puntos
90 su amiga shannon tiene un saldo de
menos 240 puntos 55 ni salir ni shannon
tienen más dinero
ambas están endeudadas lo notan tienen
un saldo negativo y tiene otro saldo
negativo justo nos preguntan cuál de
ellas está más endeudada en este caso si
yo debiera 200 puntos 90 o si debiera
240 puntos 55 pues puedo saber que este
número será una deuda mayor menos 240
puntos 55 que corresponde a shannon la
siguiente pregunta nos dice cuál de los
dos saldos tiene un mayor valor absoluto
para ello entonces buscaremos cuál es la
distancia entre este punto y el cero y
este punto y el cero compararemos y
veremos cuál de ellos es mayor en este
caso sally tiene un saldo de menos 200
puntos 90 entre menos 200 puntos 90 y el
pse
hay 200 puntos 90 de distancia mientras
que entre menos 240 puntos 55 y 0 hay
240 puntos 55 de distancia en este caso
el más grande será 240 puntos 55 y con
eso podemos saber que el valor absoluto
mayor es este 240 puntos 55 y
corresponde a shannon
vamos a comprobar nuestra última
respuesta y es correcta